feu c'était il y a dix ans la tour de
russie et ses 400 logements tombé une
première étape 1997 deux mois de
consultation des habitants et une
dernière explication de texte ce matin
casser pour reconstruire un nouveau
cadre de vie dans le quartier très
dégradée de la touche à nouveau une
barre devrait tomber la barre noire et
ses 360 logements s'est elle veut une
animée et ses habitants niveau déjà la
démolition de renoir
je pense que ça va être un bienfait car
ça va ouvrir le quartier à d'autres
perspectives
et puis à la reconstruction de petits
bâtiments qui seront plus convivial et
comment ils gèrent les gens seront plus
sociable quelque part ailleurs à plus de
rencontres voilà le projet n'est pas
figé les jeunes plaideront donc pour
l'implantation d'une maison de quartier
histoire de ne pas être oublié le centre
commercial devrait s'embellir et
retrouver d'activité de nouvelles rues
voir le jour bref le quartier de brefs
en mode c'est une très bonne chose ce
n'est qu'une partie de l'ensemble des
4000 qu'il faudra effectivement bon
assuré par la suite au niveau de la
rénovation également fort bien sûr ce
qui selon moi je n'ai pas encore des
secours est fait gifler faire il faut
les faire non c'est pas compliqué cette
année du fait qu'au départ qu'une
question de base
le groupe socialiste pour qui le grand
projet urbain doit d'abord servir à
inverser l'exclusion s'est abstenu ainsi
que le rpr et l'udf les 24 communistes
ont adopté le projet la philosophie
essentiel c'est que je souhaite vraiment
du fond du coeur que les difficultés
dans lesquelles sont les familles
trouvent là le moyen d'être infléchies
que les gens puissent un petit peu
respirer quand je crois que c'est ça qui
est urgent quoi premier
d'ici trois ans la barre noire devrait
s'effacer le temps de trouver un
relogement aux habitants ensuite le
quartier changera radicalement de
silhouettes d'ici une dizaine d'années